[Music]
amy's in dallas hi amy how are you
i'm good mr ramsay how are you better
than i deserve what's up in your world
well okay so i've been very blessed with
financial wellness mainly because ever
since i was about five
i was always asking my dad questions and
so he taught me
um
a lot of your principles really
um
so when i first graduated college
i i figured out what i needed to live on
and saved all the rest pretty much um
so what that trickled down to is i'm now
married i have two kids
and
i had been investing in my company stock
for a long time thinking
this is going to be my kids college fund
until i actually have them because i
can't put it five to nine
on a blank person um
but now that i have a good chunk of
money in there because i didn't take it
out because it was just skyrocketing so
i figured i'd ride the wave
but now i have a my daughter's five and
my son is two
i'm thinking
you know maybe i should withdraw some of
this and pull the trigger
and pay off the house which is our only
debt and
front load
both of their five two nines so that i
don't have to think about it ever again
do you have enough stock to do both of
those things
it's about 450 000. so yeah and how much
is do you own your home
70 000.
yeah you need to do this tonight
okay i figured you'd probably say that
but i was just a little worried about
the tax implications of a big
lump sum of money getting
being given to me well what do you think
the uh what do you think your gain on it
is what do you have invested in this 400
000 yeah honestly i think the gains are
like 300 and keep in mind i don't have
to sell all of it because obviously if i
front load a 529 i could put like 90k
and 1 and 30k in the other and based on
calculations i think that'll be okay
when they turn 18.
um and then 70k on the house and so i
should still have like 200k left over in
there but on the gains of that 200k
especially if i strategically sell like
not the ones that were purchased within
the last year
uh
you know i think my gains on it it's
probably a hundred thousand dollars yeah
you yeah you select the it's not that
big a deal it's a 15 capital gains rate
you've owned it more than a year and so
it's 15 grand per 100 grand
it's not that big a deal okay so yeah
you need to you need to do this
yesterday and then you know and when
you're selling it you select the shares
that you last purchased
last in first out is the accounting
principle on this meaning that the most
expensive shares the ones you have the
most invested in will create the least
gain
and that should be the last ones you
purchased
so that you know
as you know as you're and then as you're
dealing with it you want to go with last
in first out
okay then what do i do after that
because now it's like
well then you have 200 000 sitting in
stock still do you want that
i don't i don't invest in single stocks
and i don't advise people to more than
10 of their net worth so is your net
worth over two hundred thousand
i mean i'm sorry over two million over
two million
uh
one point
three i think so so i think you're a
little heavy in a single stock even
after we execute the debt free on the
house and the kids
uh at 529s are set up i'd probably go a
different i'd probably liquidate some of
that and move towards mutual funds i i'm
i'm not as big a player as you are i
wanna i don't want that much risk